Did you see her a video on the moon landing?
No.
Oh,
this is one of my favorite videos we ever did.
So,
uh,
you know,
it's about how the moon land,
the,
the thesis is the moon landing could not have been faked.
It would've been harder to fake the moon landing then it would have been to,
uh,
actually go to the moon because the technology to fake it did not exist.
Like when we talked to a,
uh,
forensic film Guy,
right.
And was like,
spends,
he's got like,
he's got a fucking Oscar for,
um,
you know,
analyzing old films.
Right.
And he walked us through it.
He's like,
look,
the shadows are parallel.
Right.
They're not diverging.
You know,
a close light source.
The shadows would,
would diverge.
Right.
Um,
so wait a minute.
You know that that's like,
one of the big arguments for the moon hoax is that the shadows intersect.
The shadows indicate multiple light sources.
Well,
that is because,
uh,
when the main argument,
that's that,
that is a,
I believe that's reflected light.
Okay.
I'm getting past my memory of the segment.
Yeah.
Um,
but I used to be a full on moon hoaxer.
I fully believed we never went to,
I shouldn't have brought this up.
Watch the documentary that was on Fox TV while I was on news radio.
I was like 1995 or something like that.
I was fucking convince
these radios on my fee.
My favorite sitcoms ever by the way,
is a unacknowledged classic.
Uh,
I have watched the whole series like three times.
Um,
that show is so,
I'm sorry,
just go ahead and set this up.
Well,
anyway,
um,
back then Fox News actually aired a full one hour show calling co called
conspiracy theory.
Did we land on the moon?
And it had me fully convinced there was all this shit that they showed,
like the same background being used in multiple moon missions that were supposed
to be on completely different parts of the moon.
Like how is this possible?
It's supposed to be like nowhere near each other,
but they have the same background and that is a,
it looks like the astronauts are on wires and it looks like the light sources
are there,
multiple light sources and that the shadows are intersecting.
And you know,
all the fucking astronauts,
when they came back,
they did this,
uh,
Apollo 11 post flight,
press conference.
They look like they're completely full of shit.
I was all in dude,
all in,
all in and now you're all out.
No.
I realized,
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking.
That's one of the,
we all deal with being all in with them and with anything.
But we also found that they did fake some things for publicity purposes.
Photographs that were used that were,
uh,
photographs from tests that they did inside a warehouse with all safety
equipment,
and then they blacked out all the safety equipment in the background.
And s pawn those photos off as spacewalk photos.
But I think that's overzealous publicist.
It doesn't mean no one went to space.
Right.
It's like making leaps is the public.
Well,
what's the simplest explanation?
If it did fake some footage.
Well,
it's probably a bunch of simple explanations,
but overzealous publicists,
people wanting to show people video that they didn't have video of.
Maybe the,
the photos didn't come out so well,
so they fake some of them.
Well,
let me let,
let the,
the thing about shadows diverging,
my memory of this is,
we don't talk about that.
When people say they see the shadows diverge,
right?
If you actually go outside on a sunny day,
when you have a single point of light like that with light reflecting,
you will see two shadows of yourself going in different,
there's one dominant shadow and then there's a,
there's a secondary one,
right?
Yeah.
But if the shadow,
if the sun is actually far away,
right?
For the main shadow,
you will see the same shadows be parallel,
right?
If you had a close light source,
like on a film,
on a film set,
you see the shadows diverge,
right?
So at this film,
Forensic Guy,
come on and tell us,
look,
if you wanted to get perfectly straight light like that,
you would need lasers.
You would,
and you would also,
but you'd also need multicolored lasers because at the time all that existed
were red lasers.
Right.
They had not existed.
They're not an invented anything other than red lasers.
Right.
So NASA would have had to have multi like multi decade advanced laser light
technology in order to fake this.
Another part of it is just hard Kubrick he'd figured out,
I mean,
no,
I mean this is,
this is what we demonstrated in our segment.
You know,
another part of it is people forget the moon broadcast.
The moon landing broadcast was something like a six hour live broadcast with no
cuts,
you know,
and at the time,
that was something you could do with TV,
but you literally couldn't do it with film.
Right.
There was no way to record film as there's,
sorry,
there's no way to record TV at the time you had live TV and you had recorded
film.
Right.
So if they were going to record it in advance,
right.
And then play it back,
they would have needed a six hour long reel of tape.
So commercials and they're,
uh,
I don't believe so.
Um,
and so,
uh,
they would've had to,
should,
we should probably know if there was commercials cause that's fair point game.
But you know,
you would have needed like an enormous film canister that also didn't exist at
the time,
but he's going to have an enormous film canister.
It'd be those fucking hoaxers at NASA.
Well done.
Well part of the premise of the,
part of the premise of the,
we didn't go to the moon argument is that we didn't have the technology to go to
the moon.
So they faked it.
Right,
right.
But it's like,
okay,
well if you have to postulate that they had decades ahead of its time filmmaking
technology,
why can't you accept that they just went to the fucking moon,
you know?
So at the end when you go through all the things that would have to happen,
right,
in order to make it,
have you really go through it and look at what is the simplest explanation.
The simplest explanation is that we went to the moon because it would have been
fucking easier.
I don't know if it would've been easier.
If it was impossible to go to the moon,
it would be insanely difficult to fake,
no doubt.
But if you had an incredible budget and if you had someone who really had the
very top of the food chain knowledge,
terms of special effects,
what Kubrick did in 2001 one one was,
when was that?
When to 2001 come out and want to sell at 71 or some shit.
Yeah,
something like that.
When did that come out?
Let's see.
Yeah,
look it up.
I think it was earlier than that.
Maybe 68 68 okay,
so we're talking about before the moon landings,
Cooper cats and pretty astonishing special effects in 2001
yeah,
but the,
the,
I mean,
the argument is that like even given,
again,
this is like a filmmaker sang this,
given the film technology of the time,
the specific features that we see in the moon footage are not favorable.
You know,
another part of it is,
for instance,
the slow jumping,
right?
The slow boom,
boom.
You know,
you're on the moon,
right?
The big argument that the moon true Thurs make is that it was regular speed
footage and it was slowed down.
Right,
right.
And there's this dude on,
I can't remember the name of it.
Um,
but if you assume he's a filmmaker on youtube,
right.
And he just breaks down.
Why like the ability to overcrank and like shooting slow mo like that,
like didn't,
that wasn't how film cameras worked at the time,
you know.
Um,
uh,
and so,
you know,
couldn't air things in slow mo back then.
Um,
look you're good at,
you're good at asking questions cause you asked me to get into details that I
don't have a off the top of my head.
Um,
but that's the,
that's the argument that,
that the dude makes.
Um,
it's not one of the arguments that we make specifically on our show because we
only had six minutes,
so we did the best ones.
So always an interesting argument when you're talking about the moon learning.
I also know about how much your audience do you think is going to be fucking
furious at me for talking about this because they believe the moon landing was
faked to like 15% I was exactly going to be my guess.